where would you go if you received a
free one-month train ticket anywhere in
Europe Lu Devine and her friends already
know Bulgaria Denmark Finland Italy or
Spain
the idea was launched by the European
Parliament in 2016 the Westin Vindhya
took him to give motivation you mean
clicking the oxen delivered an internal
ticket changting from the rotation on
your own hours committed thesis or OPA
in Altima Drive open and even though
this idea is now becoming a reality
this summer 15,000 18 year olds have the
chance to receive a pass to discover up
to 30 countries in Europe
I've semester my dating Ipoh and were
the human mention and in Causton doses
enter a ticket so gave Montana tissue
had this continental institution but in
villages are tough this is a crazy
IDI become dysfunctional and yet
somebody Nestor [ __ ] came up but is it
sufficient [ __ ] yes miss Moffat agree to
participate the young candidates must be
18 on the first of July in complete a
form applications open in June the
journey starts this summer
[Music]